oh did you guys get me my
surprise touch it don't touch it why I
heard it rhymes with pp3 might bite you
I heard this is a surprise for
me yours is way smaller than mine no
mine's
a what the [__] is this CH go from TT
all right you go first you clearly got a
house do you want to see it's like a
motorcycle or something save the big
ones for lastz you got a bunch of small
ones too oh [__] these are pretty
average yeah know these are these are
actually huge I'd say like let's sit in
the chairs and do this this one's
massive yeah no this one's [__] huge
yeah there you go there you go this
one's from your biggest fan
apparently
okay I'm
him I love this who who's your who's
your biggest fan who is my biggest fan
OB I
think I say battle on
it what's the I'm him
battle it was from that guy who's like
are you him when he got nervous when he
met you at the
airport oh oh right damn that's a deep
cut oh
damn damn so this is from that guy how
did you even get in touch with
him him he said that this is from the
dude in the
airport that when I met him he said are
you him and I said yes I'm him it's kind
of crazy cuz I'm him well no I have the
shirt so I literally have a shirt that
ISS I'm him yeah but anyone could buy a
shirt I mean I got given this as a gift
so I feel like I am him I mean
it's it's on my birth certificate you
open one
now just open that right into the mic by
the way
wow it's widly what I wanted a GT
F thank you OB this is actually awesome
I'm going to masturbate with this later
actually that's don't say that dud
that's disgusting I know you work here
I'm sorry that was
weird a gift a gift from rhr it's the
employee
handbook things you can't joke
about okay do Cody from Ryan
oh another
shirt best [__] dad ever you should
be wearing this
actually cuz you're the dad of TMG
Studios me now this is great I'm going
to wear this actually I'm going to wear
this to the
hospital when Kelsey goes into
labor hey sorry I'm late I'm
here she's
like I'm like huh what do you
think all right this is from Lauren
I bet oh I hope this is hairy styles
like
locks on a piece of cardboard so I can
[Music]
just oh yeah what let's see oh it's not
a crop
top big awesome trucks and that's how I
roll God that's so much cooler than the
one you got
me that is awesome I love it to the
fastest Coast this is for your
dad
they got me they got
me all right to the fastest Co from
Santa let me just lay the mic right
there
a his dad's feet are way bigger than
that look at these [__]
things I'm a size 10
though this is from the editing
team watch this is just to be like stop
saying things we have to
cut it's just a gag ball yeah
yeah oh you got one too oh [__] yeah
let's go editing
Team all right open them at the same
time three two
one this box just
spoke ah easy
buttons y I
knew cut awesome that's great is this is
that my
voice did you AI that why does it sound
so cut that out cut that out cut that
out cut that
out that's you dude that's definitely AI
can we hear no else cut that out cut
that out that sounds like you mine
sounds like that's your like the Cadence
sounds like a like a Call of Duty like
operator cut that out cut that out yeah
cut that out
cut that out M sounds like [__] Sarah
pal cut that out oh cut that out what
you you can re-record it cut that
out cut that all right I'm I'm going to
do mine
cut
wait cut
it that's so loud this feels like porn
fingers crossed fingers crossed this
seems
like Mommy make out day the the
series it was close that's pretty close
Nature's dongs a Wily long
year why am I like rain Manning all
these gifts I could tell this is
pornography from
Izzy oh this is awesome
are these should I be wearing these when
I kill my next Lobster yeah oh bro I'm
wearing these for the rest yeah right
dude you're going to get eczema by the
end of this episode of no skin left on
your
knuckles
bro something about that magnetized me
to it why did you come towards I I
couldn't help it cut it off someone's
reaching celeb candle from the King I'm
gonna
say it's a celeb candle yeah what is
that I'm gonna guess that it's a person
in here okay it's got to be Nick
Cage did you nail it oh my
god dude you are skilled man two Cody
and Noel plus two Cody and Noel from
HR is this actually the employees
handbook
things HR told me I can't say
wowow oh it's to keep track of them I
see things I want to say at work but
can't adults coloring
book my alone time is for everyone's
safety that one's a little dark why is
there a
gun what is that what image is that
pancakes
with I don't know I don't know where you
do is it just adhesive suction cut base
holds to any wood or metal desktop
surface set that [__] up right here
dude
okay that's so fun trying to have a
conversation with someone uh-huh
just sponging it so
hard I saw the suction cup sort of come
[Laughter]
off you make it
jump I'm just my it's going to [__]
come right at
me